I'm Danica Patrick and I'm pretty  intense are you someone that believes  there's spirituality and then religious  like you're either religious or  spiritual you know my whole relationship  with that see why a calling how did you  be how did you get introduced from India  I became best friend  okay oh you call your Col your group the  villagers okay your fans  he said one and I wanted to come and  spend the night in my dorm so  sacré dorms so that night I went into  his dorm room and there was a creepy  like almost you're like whoa why why am  i so connected to this photo of this man  yeah  st. Teresa say st. Francis of Assisi the  energy so you know you love somebody you  want to love everything right so because  he was from India I wanted to love  because because he would read so if it  all stem from my love of them you know I  was  yeah it wasn't the religion that my yeah  my connection with the people that have  inspired me on a throne right so I want  to think of as you know  you